Oh shit, sorry.
Guys, I've been so out of it, guys.
Oh yeah, I won a tournament.
I can chill as much as I want.
Let me fucking...
All right, let me get my chat in here.
Buy my controller.
I won a tournament.
This is my chat.
in the chat um let me just like let me fix this real quick
i'm tired okay pre-order my controller before it's gone
there you go one week left one week left to buy guys you
know what else is a tournament winning uh item my fucking
msi 500 hertz monitor i told you guys there's like got that
monitor everything was different also i haven't even made
the tweet about winning in tournament.
I'm going to yoying their screen.
I'm going to yoying someone's screenshot.
I'm going to, okay, what is uh, do you have a graphic of of
us winning?
Alright, here we go.
Let's see.
Um.
There's another VTuber tournament.
What the fuck?
The next day?
had another rival's tournament is crazy another vtuber
rival's tournament it's crazy uh thank you guys i'm sorry
i'm like i'm like so out of it like i'm so guys i want oh
jen you're right what another i forgot bro things are
blurring together guys i i actually i don't i don't know you
guys remember but um you know how like after the interview i
literally disassociated for like a couple of minutes like I
was not okay I like right after I left the call with Connor
and IMS I think it was just like I forgot I was like on I
forgot I was streaming like I literally forgot that I was
still streaming I thought like oh shit now I'm off stream I
can I left the call and I was like it's over like i don't
have to like i'm off like i'm not like i know i was like
wait i'm streaming i i was like wait a minute oh wait i'm
streaming too i forgot
yeah oh yes this is so seen because i it's just so much
adrenaline and everything i need um i need to like no there
it's youtube side that's so that sucks that um um uh that uh
what was I gonna say oh yeah it sucks that my last game
YouTube got hit got hit hard that was that was unfortunate
but what could you do at least the did the VOD survive I was
too scared to watch the VOD I watched a bit of the the
replay on oh the VOD is fine that's good I watched a bit of
the replay of the games themselves on on Seedog and
Aramouse's stream.
Let's see how people were thinking.
I also watched a little bit of Shoto's POV during that
unfortunate game that I had against them.
I need you guys to know, I was not, my hands were shaking
the entire time for that very first game.
I was not aiming at all.
Like, I'm surprised I hit any shots.
During that first game.
So, um, I don't know if you guys know that.
I think you guys could tell.
And then after that, um, after, uh, after the first game,
like, my aim, like, relaxed after that.
Um, it was fine after that, yeah.
Um, but like after the first game, I was fine with my aim.
Yo, you guys, you guys like how aggressive I was?
Because I, okay, like, I would never do this.
And, and if I was in my top 500.
lobby I would never been that aggressive but I knew I knew I
could out aim at least 70% of at least 70 to 80% of the
people in that tournament so I knew I could like even as
rocket as rocket too because like they don't expect the
rocket damage is actually insane rockets damage is insane up
close and no one ever expects the rocket to shoot back so
when I rock it all I was just like, that's right, bitch.
I was just like, I was like, get over here.
I fucking mowed down an entire tank into like, to zero HP is
crazy.
Uh, that's close.
But the thing is, I know I could get, I knew I could get
away with it in this tournament.
Um, but, um, I, I, I obviously in rank, in rank because um
all the fucking rank players like all the top 500 players
would fucking shit on me and shut me down but i knew i knew
like even as luna the moment i swapped the luna oh my god
luna feels so slow after i started playing gambit for those
who don't know luna is not meta anymore so that's why we
avoided playing luna um and we only had to play luna during
like certain scenarios like the storm vault you have to play
luna for storm vault um So, if she felt so slow when I was,
like, swapping to Gambit, like, aim-wise as well.
Like, it was so weird trying to aim on Luna because I'm not
used to aiming on Luna with, like, after playing Gambit for
so long.
Like, yeah, she's finally freed.
We're finally free.
Yeah, I was glad that...
Now you guys can see why I was fucking...
guys can tell see that i would like 1v1 other players and i
was that confident as as uh like there was i had so much
mobility it's actually crazy as gambit you can have so much
fucking ability you can see me like go in and then go out
and i'm still alive like that's why yeah and um um i use
gambit very aggressively the difference between a bad gambit
and like a good gambit is um you use your abilities
aggressively so you don't use it to heal you literally use
it to just anti things and like you just play as anna that's
really it um um and he's just like he like people are like
oh he's the kierko he's he's the anna he's the anna of
marvel rivals so and he has you can see like how if you guys
ever when you were watching the games um and every time my
back
instantly and like killed the dive that's why i was not
afraid of like flankers everyone they're like oh what about
the flankers i was like just mark them if you mark them i
can kill them because i have so much like my kit is just so
fucking strong yeah it's just so strong like um uh gash can
you welcome to tamil find welcome welcome um uh fiction name
is super chat thank you thank you unfortunately no but there
is a way to watch the bots wink wink wink you might have to
ask a dragon about it there is a way to still access the
streams um but you have to ask a dragon about it because i i
don't know um oh man yeah i heard heavenly like locked in
with dps by playing like blasting music out and fucking just
going ham.
Okay, I gotta make my my victory tweet real quick, guys.
Give me a sec.
Let me see.
Let me make my victory be organizers for anything and
understandings but amazing despite all the all the guys okay
sorry i have to make my like my victory tweet before i go
before we go back here because i don't want to um i don't
want to uh wait too long for it because everyone's still
sort of awake um anyway sorry i'm like all over the mine is
all over place i'm i'm i cannot believe we won There's a
controller vibe where it asks you for, yeah, you can
customize the controller to have the, I heard that the, the
pro controller doesn't have the vibration, only because, oh,
wait, are you talking about something?
I thought he was, yeah, you can customize it.
You can add it in with your own customization to it.
Don't, thank you for the, well, thank you for the five gift
of ships, thank you, thank you, unless you mean something
else.
Unless you mean something else.
All the setbacks and last minute.
All the setbacks.
Everything went.
The production.
The event itself went so smoothly.
And was so professionally done.
Thank you.
got top five okay i'm gonna be like what are the same day
for mob for marvel rivals got top 500 and won the first
vtuber cup posted by sea dog and iron mouse i really
appreciate the organized for being amazing despite the
events that went so smoothly and so professionally done um
and so went so smoothly today on today it was so
professionally done um i didn't expect to make to the finals
and even winning the champ winning it all
I almost dropped out because wait should I say that I almost
dropped out I literally had a breakdown last night because I
almost dropped out no I don't need to add that yet I'll tell
you guys the story okay Uh, dropping a little fun fact,
guys.
Uh, felt, yeah, I was, I'd fucking, I was like, I hope we
win one game.
I, because, like, I said, we literally, as a full team
together, like, with all six of us, we had two hours
together of all six of us.
And then, uh, five of us, we had four hours of practice.
But I literally saw some teams that were, like, um, in the
VC for two days, morning to night, for hours.
And I was like, oh, no, are we not practicing enough?
I was, like, so scared.
And I was like, oh, my gosh, oh.
And then, like, you know, I was like, oh, we don't have, you
know, we don't have a, we don't have, like, you know, like
an X-Pro DPS player or like, like, in a top 500 DPS player,
you know, or like in an X-Pro in different types of games or
anything or just like, you know, gifted, you know, you guys
can be like, oh, dokey but you got top 500 in like overwatch
and apex and stuff like that but like i play support now in
rivals and that is because like you know like i would see
like the enemy dps players like you know i would see sk or
like blur like like just walking around and i couldn't do
anything about it i have to like all i could do like i want
to shoot them but i mean i did shot blur a couple of times
and also SK a couple of times but it was very there were
also very risky moves to take for me as a support because
when I die my team doesn't get kills anymore so so um so
like it was very risky for me to to try and take those shots
to try and do one like like 1v1 against like the really,
really, really good DPS players.
So I was very nervous because we didn't, I guess like we
didn't, our team was just very, very well-rounded.
Like we were so lucky to have such an amazing combination.
Like even though it was like assigned, pre-assigned, our
team was just really good in terms of like, we're all just
good, well-rounded individuals.
that we could literally just play anything yeah like we
could play even though we're not all of our average was a
bit lower uh was a bit lower compared to others um um we
managed to like we were so flexible with everything yeah um
and you know i know i i had really good igls and stuff like
that i yeah oh my god i just watched the vod of them just i
sorry i accidentally had a vod of the the Shoto match and
then where the fuck did I come from where I just suddenly
fucking killed the Magneto I don't know like I just saw
Magneto die now like where the like by me I was like where
the fuck did I come from like I'm sorry yeah yeah I was like
yeah fuck you muted like fear what bitch like fear this
um um any any oh wait whoa the muted situation was crazy
yeah yeah yeah heavenly was our secret weapon regarding like
the flex uh being the flex like actual dp by the way he was
he was he was the role he chose was dps um he was like my
first choice is dps but we're but he was the strongest tank
player in our entire team so we're like we're putting on
tank um um because like obviously our other dps player was
melee only so you know when they started playing flyers when
they started fucking playing flyers we were like oh shit
okay swap what are you gonna do punch them from the sky yeah
that ain't season one iron fist bro like yeah
yeah it was our hawk like that's why i said don't say
anything i told my team private your profiles don't say
anything because they were all they all the other teams were
analyzing our mains we're trying to figure out our mains and
everything yeah uh oh can i get my second happy birthday
from my oh she also congrats on winning a tournament gordon
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you you have
your birthday is two days don't worry don't worry i'll still
be here to wish you a Gordon happy birthday to you happy
birthday to you happy birthday dear Gordon happy birthday to
you yeah happy birthday yeah yeah he was yeah his Hawkeye
got banned instantly but he was a he was literally a hitscan
DPS player so like he could just play other hitscans like he
was a hitscan projectile DPS player like he was our non
melee character so it didn't matter if they Target band,
Hawkeye, because he could still play, you know, he could
still fucking play, like, the other gun shooty DPS play,
DPS, yeah, um, uh, so, yeah, I'm just, I'm really fucking,
uh, proud of my team for it, um, I, bro, like, the amount
of, like, I literally woke up, five, uh, I woke up at, like,
10, a.m yeah i woke up at 10 a.m and started researching
today because i started researching um my teams because like
uh started researching all the like all the enemy teams and
stuff because okay this is like really fucked up but like um
i know like others were doing the same like there was a lot
of money on the line too and like you know uh others were
also doing something so i assume others were doing something
similar because i saw people private their profiles um after
joining the But like, I know it's like pretty messed up, but
it's research.
I like, that's, I find this fun.
I find the strategizing and trying, like, trying to figure
out, like, what to play against.
Because that's, that's literally competitive.
Like, you can say, like, oh, it's for fun.
But like, that's, it's still competitive in a way.
Like, it's still a competitive environment.
yeah i did for the love of the game but and i love i love
like the strategies and like strategize because it's rock
paper scissors bandline is rock paper scissors um if you get
a good bandline you fucking win the game so uh so like what
i did basically i don't know i think i said it before but i
looked up everybody's profiles like one by one because they
uh gave us access to uids um and I looked it up one by one
and then all the ones that had their profiles open I looked
at history and then I see all the comps they played together
in the six stack so that's that's literally what I did and
um so and then like also if they are open I see what they
mean I just look at what they made and see the thing is this
is what my bad line was I look for players I look for
players who have been who are newer in the game and if
they're playing important This is why our team was the only
team that banned Emma because from my research Um, this is
the only reason why our like though other all the other
teams they didn't ban Emma What I noticed because, uh, they
had their profiles open was that I realized Um, I realized
that they only they only had time to learn one new character
and emma their only tank player learned all they did was
learn emma for like their and their second most played tank
was mag with 11 minutes so they i noticed that oh wait
they're only their main only tank player and you guys
remember in the VOD in the VOD where uh where they were like
where I was like guys read what my discord message because
we were watching we were watching uh we were watching dubie
and amelie's I think it was like yeah dubie versus amelie
and then uh amelie versus uh uh fuck oh my gosh my mind is
blurring together who is the 13 this who is the 13 guys it
was uh Shoto.
It was Amalee versus Shoto.
And what I typed in the Discord was like, do you notice how
they are playing one tank and their one tank is their Emma
player?
Like...
So my brain is like frazzled right now because I've been
doing a lot of thinking.
And that was why I was typing in the Discord server.
And I was like, don't be afraid.
They're literally playing one tank and their one tank is
their Emma one trick.
And that's why I banned Emma You know how I got this strat?
Because fucking XQC during the XQC tournament, Target Band
Tyler won.
Despite our team being incredibly stacked.
And all Tyler won did.
Great guy.
Very funny.
But all he did on Hulk when we did a D1 XQC, Target Band are
poor new player who can only play Venom.
He targeted Ben Tyler 1 We were We won a majority of our
games XQC lost all his games We went to knockout stages And
XQC's team Knocked us out Because they realized Wait Tyler 1
can only play Venom And then we had to put Tyler 1 On Hulk
and he fucking fed his ass off and then we got knocked out
we were the favorites to get first or second and then we got
knocked out and from that was where I learned my lesson
this was where I realized this was the strat because my team
was like no we shouldn't Emma, we have to ban Hella and
Siloc.
I was like, no, you don't understand.
It was a life lesson.
That what he did to us was a fucking life lesson.
And then after we got knocked out by XKC's team, when we
were the favorites, like instantly gone.
It was like group stages and we got he lost every game.
We won every game.
So we're like, this is easy.
You know, like, oh, we're against the team that lost every
game.
Like, we're supposed to win this and then he they realized
wait we can target bad tyler one because that's their second
tank and then everything fell apart because it became a 5v6
because tyler one had to learn an entire new tank during
that during that one that like live on that game uh So my
team was like, no, no, bad Hela Silos, because they were
very scary.
Because we don't want to deal with Namor Team Up with Hela.
And also, we don't want to deal with SK Silos.
And I was like, no, guys, we have to ban Emma.
You don't understand.
Their main tank player can only play Emma.
At the moment we take that away from him, their entire front
line collapses.
I was like, you don't understand.
Like, and then they're like, and I pulled up the excuse me
thing.
It happened to me in this tournament.
You don't understand.
I literally got knocked off because of that.
Like,
I was like, we have to do this.
Like, yeah.
Yeah, so.
so like because you know having you know they lost their
main tank so like the the the strat was just basically by
losing their main tank because it's very hard to learn a new
character after spending hours on the one tank you know the
one character that you were told to learn uh for the last
two days and suddenly bam the band went in like so so it
essentially becomes a 5v6.
Okay, also, the other thing was that I was going to try and
ban Hella too after that.
I was going to be like Emma Hella because I was like, let's
give SK SILOC because I feel bad because like she was Target
banned the entire time.
And then obviously my team was like, don't do that, bro.
You're like, because like, you know, Yannirs has only played
Hella the entire time.
And I was like, bro, let's just let SK play SILOC, man.
She got Target banned.
And then my team was like, no, that's bullying you're gonna
you're bullying the two new players for my batting their new
their characters and i was like but i just want to give
eskade siloed and that's why i was like let's gotcha it guys
let's but then but then we got domination i was like no
gotcha i ain't fighting siloed on domination i okay it was
because we were guaranteed in the final so at that point i
didn't care whether we I was like, no, I don't want to die
to Scylok on domination because domination is the best map
for Scylok So I was like, no, I was gonna be nice, but never
mind I was just like I I just hated playing domination with
Scylok like against Scylok I was just like, I'm sorry the
map picked the map didn't want me like
Yeah, that one map changed my entire my entire career Hmm
yeah um jacquardo thank you super chat thank you thank you
some may underestimate dokey coming out with big brain
stress because they don't expect research mode dokey but
when it's rival she uses 110 of the brain thank you super
chat i think i could be i i don't think i actually no i
don't think i'm a good analyst honestly i had a lot of help
from um figuring out how to analyze situations um from other
pro players just watching pros and like just talking to
other pro players and also like talking to like the managers
of uh pro teams so it helped a lot trying to figure because
like you know i was very undecided about some things so like
so like they helped me a lot when they um when they were
like teaching me how to analyze the situation because i also
didn't play this season a lot that's also because like like
i literally started this season three days ago I I literally
started this season three days ago so I was like not not
like not like very informed like I wasn't very informative
of like what to fucking swap you know like I was like do I
do this or do I do that like because I was very like I'm
very proud of my team for being able to like think for
themselves about counterswapping too so I'm glad that they
also thought for themselves as well um and being able to
like because when i don't know what to counter swap i was
just like just they they were like i'll do this then but i
did like i did like been more pro i was very proactive in
the end about counter swapping because like i didn't want
people them to hesitate because i was like we got i like i
was just like guys come on guys we got we got we have to
like think really fast because i like the thing about me
because i have the game a top 500 hiring player so um um you
know we our duty as like especially a support player we have
to react fast basically we have to react and think very fast
about the situation because like one second can cost like
the entire game so i have to like be like i actually have to
take control about the swapping be like swap now swap that
swap now swap this like i was like he's I was like, he's
Moon Knight.
Go, go back to spawn room and go get off of Loki.
And then the user was like, wait, right now?
Like, the game's like, yes, right now.
Yes, right now.
Get off of Loki.
Like, I don't care if you have...
Yeah, I realized, like, after the first map, I had to be
more...
I have to be more proactive with calling for swaps and
stuff.
It's because, like, I am also used to it for, you know, I
started playing competitive in Overwatch, and Overwatch was
all about counterswapping, and so you had to think fast.
And then Apex, it's all about rotations and everything.
And so that taught me about, like, rotations and, like,
positioning and stuff.
And so, like, combining those two into rivals, Helped out a
lot.
I was really impressed with how you're able to micromanage
just enough to wrangle your team.
Yeah, it's very hard on Gambit because Gambit has a lot of
things to do.
So like my brain was actually on fucking overtime trying to
figure out like what to Like what to say what to do on
Gambit only because like I have like 50 other buttons to
play use like and like be aware of my surroundings too.
Okay, but yeah out um i'm glad i was able to play gambit
because i don't know if you guys noticed but gambit is a
very very broken like i literally got to okay you guys do
notice because i always i'm so humbled but i sort of talk
about it a bit you know you know i sort of talk about it
here and there but you know how i got top 500 in two days by
playing gambit yeah but he is so good on um he is he is the
best support character like in this game and i'm there's no
way they're keeping him like that and there's no way they're
keeping him like that though because rank one two three four
and five currently is literally one guy one pro player who
just plays gambit and he got rank one two three and four and
five right now and his play style is basically i basically
took my play style is basically his play style i took how
i've analyzed how he plays and i just played like him yeah
that's that's how fucking broken gambit is at the moment
yeah His name is Saipay, but yeah, he's like rank 1 to 5 at
the moment on Gambit.
So, that's why you see how aggressive, like, I do heal.
Like, I'd never use my heals.
You can tell that I'd never use my healing cards.
And all I did was just anti-people over and over again.
Because, like, his primary heal is just so strong already.
So, like, it doesn't, like, he doesn't need to use his cards
to heal.
because it takes fucking forever to charge.
It's a good...
I'm actually having a lot of fun playing Gambit, too.
Yeah, his anti-heal is just way too strong to use it for
anything else.
Like I said, it's just Anna.
It's just really Anna.
Oh, sorry.
But, yeah, okay, I forgot.
Fuck, I was supposed to make my tweet.
Yeah, sorry.
Give me a sec.
Let me...
I was supposed to make my tweet, and I forgot it.
Okay.
so i didn't expect to make it uneven winning it it all so i
really couldn't i really couldn't have done it done it
without my team so please check them out they're all
wonderful players who deserve um they're all wonderful
players well a wonderful
Insane Fraggers.
Uh, and then I'll do the Twitter ads.
Okay, what's their Twitter ad?
I don't remember what their Twitter ad is.
I know Isa made a tweet, so I'm just yonking that.
Uh, I'm just gonna yonk that real quick.
Uh, thanks Isa.
Let me copy your homework, but I'll change it a little bit.
Okay.
Heavenly.
all right and then isa no one can tell her i'm literally i'm
just taking her i'm just taking her fucking twitter handle
thing i'm just copying pasting that because she did the
thing uh
i didn't eat dinner yet by the way i lied i know i said let
me push a 30 minutes to grab dinner and I didn't eat dinner.
Alright, I appreciate Orangers for being amazing.
Despite all the setbacks of the event, despite all the
setbacks, events that went so smoothly and was so perfect,
so smoothly today and was so professional.
I didn't expect to make it all the way to the finals.
uh, and even when I really couldn't have done one of my
teams, so please check out my own wonderful, insane
braggers.
And made me so proud.
Also, huge shout out.
Also, huge shout out to our coach.
At Super.
To our coach, too.
Okay, let me add that.
Also, huge shout out to our coach, too.
Who helped us.
Who helped us with.
who helped us figure out comps and how to play no, you know
what yeah, just, yeah, there you go who helped us find
scrims and wait, I don't know how to say who helped us, did
I say that?
I don't know if I should give too much detail like
yeah that's it to our coach there you go yeah there you are
to say also huge shout out to your coach too yeah i'm tired
i'm tired thank you every who helped us who helped us
prepare and stayed up to give individual coaching for those
who wanted it yeah I shouldn't know he didn't stay up, lie.
Sorry, he didn't stay up.
He left after an hour or two.
I don't know how long he stayed because I was doing my
endurance battlefield stream.
I didn't know.
It still counts.
Oh.
Thank you, everyone, for supporting me and my team.
Me and my team.
All right.
I'm so happy to have made it this far.
There you go.
No dinner because Jolly Bee was gone.
closed, sad face.
I love the air that you would see.
Oh my gosh, I'm so tired.
My eyes actually, like, feel so heavy.
I think it's like, I'm not tired.
I think I'm, like, I'm not, like, physically tired.
I'm, like, mentally tired.
I think that that's it.
I don't physically feel tired.
I'm just mentally so exhausted.
From, because I had to use...
so much of my brain power to play that entire tournament
because I was, you know, I was watching some of the other
streams.
I think my biggest advantage was that I have so much
experience in tournaments that like I know how to lead a
team in terms of like IGLing because I have so much
experience
rank lobbies that like um um it gave our team an advantage
because then we knew what to do like we had a plan each time
we don't hesitate to so like that was like our one of our
big because i was watching like the other like i was
watching like i think like two of the povs i didn't i didn't
watch dubie's pov for like her matches but um like the there
was no like i guess there was were all trying to like decide
as a team on what to do and what not to do but for me i was
like no we're doing this you know they're like do it yeah i
was like no we're doing this i was like you you do this
we're gonna do this next and then we're gonna do this next i
was like don't all everyone do not all but like yeah yeah
i'll be like uh uh i was like Yuzu, don't come out.
Keep hiding.
Yeah, because I know Yuzu wants to join the fight.
And I was like, Yuzu, don't come out of the hole.
Keep fucking hiding.
and I'm like, don't awe, and then Heavenly throws his awe.
And I'm like, bro!
And so, Luna, the thing is, um i know kikio was very shy um
she was a she's a very shy player apparently um gomez told
me that when i wasn't in the college she talked a lot so i
think she was very intimidated by me um like because like he
was doing individual coaching um for anyone that wants it
and he was doing individual coaching for anyone that wanted
like you know extra help like while i was playing
struggling playing battlefield and he told me that um there
was like four of them in the car and she was like yapping a
lot and like she's like you were just very he was like yeah
you're like you're very intimidating yeah when i get like
super serious you know i get super serious uh um during like
uh when you know because i i love competitive games in
general so I didn't, she didn't say she didn't have all, you
know, she could, you know, she was, I was like, Luna, oh,
Luna, oh, because I didn't see her all, I didn't realize she
all did, because I think I was dead, um, so I saved my all,
because I was waiting for her to all, um, and then I tapped,
I was like, oh, you didn't have all, I was just like, uh, I
was like, oh, wait, I pressed tab, I was like, wait, no,
never mind, you didn't have all, I was like, what the fuck,
why aren't you all, but she didn't say anything, She didn't
say anything until I pressed staff.
Yeah.
Yeah, she was so scared to tell me she didn't have, oh,
yeah.
I'm just glad that we still won the fight, though.
Yeah, the others had to say it, yeah.
Oh, yeah, fucking, give me a sec.
I still need to finish my tweet.
I'm still trying to finish my tweet.
I'm still.
My God, I forgot to make a waiting room, too, for this
stream.
Like, I was all over the place, guys.
I was all over the place.
Like, I still haven't.
Okay, what a sane day for Marvel rivals.
God, top 500, won the first video cup hosted by C-Dog and
RMS.
I really appreciate the audience for being amazing, despite
all the setbacks.
It went so smooth in the day and was so professional in
that.
And I didn't expect to marry all the fans and even winning
it all.
Okay, I love my team, so please check out the all-wonderful
and insane fraggers.
It made me so proud.
Um, each of them played a huge part, huge part in our
victory.
And her coach who helped us prepare.
Um, and, yeah.
Everyone who's around my team, I'm so happy to have made it
this far.
Uh, W event.
I should say that.
W.
Um, um, uh, thank you, everyone!
Where's the word of my team?
I said, how to make it this, to have made it this far, to
have made it this far.
Um, and I'm just so proud of everyone.
Okay.
Alright, there you go.
Alright, let me grab a screenshot.
I'm gonna grab my top 500 screenshot and put it.
And include it as well.
okay all right let's see when did i guys when did i okay
time stamp time i'm looking at time stamp when i include my
top five showed you guys my top 500 okay top five guys did
you guys not time stamp it okay okay guys where's the time
stamp i'm taking a screenshot no it was after i we got into
the finals and i was like i oh yeah when we got confirmed to
be in the finals where is it no the lag made no it was like
before we were in the finals okay get second point uh where
is it wins to uh gets final push i don't know okay winning
wait where is it it's somewhere
uh okay here you are all right here we are okay this is
where all right time stamps were like yeah sorry i'm so
sorry it was it was literally youtube side i was literally
watching i was literally like my i was watching streams and
stuff and it didn't buffer at all i was so surprised all
right let me grab a screenshot real quick oh yeah by the way
like i said um i'm in another in um next month but this time
it's like it's it's like uh other it's like pro players and
content creators uh but like they're making sure that we
each get our own like we each are like like you know it's
like drafting it's like a drafting phase and also uh they're
divided by roles so they got like people like fill up every
role and stuff and everything so it's not like uh um it's
not like you know what's the word sorry my brain is so fried
like they're like okay like each captain has to draft a
support and then you know grab a support each captain has to
grab this like that and that like yeah basically has to grab
like a content creator or some shit like all right here you
go all right there you go oh my gosh give me a second i'm
trying to find all right here you go i'm gonna grab that
screenshot guys
that screenshot of me getting top 500 everyone whoa there we
go he he he
there we go what a wonderful day all right here is my top
500 and then I'm going to yonk Isas.
Okay, now I won't yonk Isas.
I'm going to look at, all right.
Where did we win?
I'm glad that they let us restart the map too.
I'm glad.
I'm really happy about that because I felt so bad.
I felt so bad that I requested a map, like, you know, be
like, please honor this band.
very happy that they honored it.
I got really worried that they were like, no!
Yeah.
I was worried they'd be like, no.
Wait, is the VOD okay?
Is it laggy?
I can't tell.
Wait, let me.
Like, it's the VOD okay?
The VODs are okay.
Okay.
Good.
That's good.
Okay, I think it's still, yeah.
oh there we go i'm glad all right let me victory dokey bird
i'm gonna victory dokey bird and then i don't know do i get
the one where do i use the screenshot where they're like
vtuber cup standings or do i do the victory okay maybe i'll
do victory uh uh you know i'm gonna grab the connor connor
video let's see there we go team standings there we go i'll
grab that bucket there we go all right insane also too oh
yeah thank you okay also insane fights against insane games
against every
uh my brain had to go full full nerd mode to figure out how
to how figure out how to counter everyone how to let's see
count okay awesome games games against all all the teams my
brain i go Go nerd mode.
Figure out how to counter each and every fight.
Go third.
Go third nerd mode.
Uh, yeah, it keeps getting longer and longer.
I'm sorry.
I'm tired.
My, okay, I'll show you guys my spreadsheet.
I'll show it to you guys.
I slide.
It's not.
Here we go.
Okay.
This is me.
Okay, wait, let me...
There you go.
Okay, this is not all of it, though.
Bada-dada-dada-dada.
Bum.
I'll show you guys my spreadsheet.
There's more, by the way, to it.
I have, like...
one where it's like our main comps what do we play when they
do this but i'll show you this oh yeah let's see actually
okay uh oh yeah let me double check everything i wrote here
did i wrote anything bad no i didn't okay here you go here
you go here you go team show though release the documents.
These are our bandline.
They also have a strong sidelock.
Here's our, this is what I posted in, so I just look at it
whenever.
And these are like, they have an band, I was like, what maps
are Angela?
You know?
And then, and then there's like, Dubee's team.
The Dubee files, yeah, and then here you go.
Here's our band during scrims because they did a scrim they
did a scrim against like uh but i should have told them like
they're fucking around like uh and these are not the actual
comps you're playing because i know their quick play comps
were their real comps um they did a scrim like uh dubie and
shoto scrimmed each other and uh and uh but they were
fucking around with their comps for it and also their band
lied so i knew that this wasn't a real comps and i looked at
the quick play and that's where i found the real comps
because i was like yeah like if they're six stacking quick
play real comps because it was consistent and then so I was
like Hela's main band and Penny obviously we swapped that
around later I swapped that around later after that because
I was just like oh we later were like we banned Bucky Hela
because we realized at first we're like all of them could
play Penny and then we're like oh wait no Bucky Hela is a
better strat just because like we saw we saw, you know,
because luckily, Duby was the first, Duby and Amalie were
the, was the first team to play against each other.
So, we noticed that Blur was really good at Bucky, so we
swapped our band line, or I swapped the band line, and was
like, okay, we banned Tella and Bucky.
And, at first we wanted to ban Groot, because we realized
they only played Groot.
They really only played Groot.
So, then I was just like, but so that was like, we're doing
the same thing as like bad Emma because that's the only
thing they play.
But then we're like, oh, it's fine.
Like their DPS is a lot scarier than like, because their
tanks can swap to something else, even though they have to
swap to, uh, they have to swap to, uh, DPS.
But, um, we just realized just Bucky, we don't want to deal
with Bucky up because we have a Loki.
And also like, you know, they had to play Moon night to
counter our Loki and we so we're like we have to ban Bucky
because you know he's just gonna farm our clones and we're
like hell out we don't want to deal with a team up because
we notice how good they are at the team up so we don't have
a hell up and a name more player um and this was our second
one here that's uh so yeah ban Emma yeah that's they have a
player that only knows how to Emma.
There it is.
And then my team argued against it and was like, um, my team
was like, no, don't ban Emma.
We have to ban Hella.
We have to ban Hella because it's scarier.
The name where team up is scary.
I was like, no, I played these games before.
I, I was like, I play these.
got knocked out because my one trick could only play venom
and we were the favorites and we got knocked out by the by
the last place team because they banned my one trick i was
not having history repeat itself
I was like, get rid of the front line.
So my strat was to get rid of the front line because like I
said, when the front line falls, everything falls.
Thank you, Pat.
Thank you, XQC, for giving me enough trauma to do this to
someone else.
I continue the cycle.
I continue this cycle.
I can't give me.
I'm making the tweet.
Games against all the teams from Red Hat on the reality
counter each and every fight.
You were all a pleasure.
You were all a pleasure to...
To play against...
Um...
Do we...
I'm gonna leave...
Shoulda all put up a great...
A great fight.
Uh...
Okay, there you are.
I did the tweet.
Okay.
Before the tournament...
Oh yeah.
Honor and strategic guys strategize and say everyone on the
fly.
Team doobie.
All right, there we go.
All right, here.
Insane games against all...
This is a long-ass tweet, but I feel like it says everything
I want to say.
Yippee.
There you go.
I made my tweet.
Alright.
I did it.
Yippee.
My little yippee.
No dub.
We got yippee.
What's...
I think yippee is better than W event, guys.
W event.
You guys want to just reply W event to my...
tweet if you want like
you guys can write W event in my reply if you really want to
okay uh let's see
can't believe they target bad me I'm just a support player
I'm just a support player, guys.
How come I got targeted?
All right, okay, so I'll tell you guys more about the
details.
Okay, so I almost dropped out of the, obviously, the whole,
I mean, that's basically the whole story.
I almost dropped out of the tournament because I was so
stressed out.
And like, I've been very stressed out the last.
month and um there was like a lot of like balancing stuff
going on last minute and a lot of people being um replaced
and everything and then i felt so bad because um i didn't
also i didn't really want to be captain i didn't want to be
captain at all um because like you know i feel like if we
could make our own name instead of being like team dokeybird
you know like that would be less stressful but it was like
team dokeybird i represent the entire team and then you know
i and the fact that i had to do like the interviews and
everything and like and like i knew it because i was captain
i have to do the interviews and stuff so it was like so much
and there was so much so many eyes on me like literally when
they announced it everyone was like dokeybird's gonna sweep
the entire tournament and everything and there was so much
pressure on me because everyone knows that i'm like the
marvel rivals youtuber and so like but then i got really
nervous because when we were seeing when we got our team
thing when we got the team list um uh um i was very worried
because like i said it was 70 support players so a lot of
people had to offer and we didn't really have like you know
like pure tank players so people that's why that's also why
i was so aggressive i um i got like that's why i was so
aggressive because i knew a lot of people are off rolling so
like even the tanks so i knew like an actual tank player
would fucking shut me down instantly um so but i knew i was
like you're off rolling you know i was like you you're
off-rolling i'm coming for you like that's i was just like i
was like fighting everyone because i knew they were
off-rolling um so i was not scared because they don't they
don't know their uh their full potential as that character
because if you saw me fucking go up against the strange you
know what i'm told at i'm like told that like never as a
support player never try not even as a support or dps player
you're never supposed to do a 1v1 against the strange
because the strange will always win the fight but i was like
you were off bro like i know you don't know how to kill me
like so i'm also like funnish here too because i was like i
know you don't know how to kill me bro i so so that's why i
was so fucking aggressive because I knew a lot of the people
were off-rolling.
So, and same with my team.
Like I said, we didn't really have a tank player.
But Balina was a melee DPS player.
He mostly plays, like, he mostly plays all, like, Iron Fist
and Mr. Fantastic, which is a crazy hero pool.
Like, so we had to stick Heavenly onto tank.
was our DPS player as well.
But we realized that a lot of lower, low ranked players or
like, you know, the rank disparity of players, they don't
know how to play against Iron Fist and Mr. Fantastic.
So especially an Iron Fist that has a team supporting him.
That's why, and because teams already struggle with
Daredevil, like if he knew Daredevil, it would have been
perfect.
But if he knew Daredevil, it would have been so fucking not
fair.
um because daredevil is like the fucking um the fucking most
broken dps character right now in in rivals um uh but like
even then like there's also like it um if they knew like
they just need a bucky to counter that's why we were banning
bucky too because bucky counters uh iron fist as well um um
so so i was you know i was really nervous about it because
um um a lot of the other teams they had really really good
dps players um that were like you know um that were like
even if they are not even their ranking rivals isn't high
they've like peaked higher in different games and um or they
have like a higher rank average our rank average was not
that high uh like you know user literally learned the game
two days like not learn the learn the game but literally um
try to pick up the game two days ago um i mean she i think
she played quick play before when the game first came out
but you know she didn't play a lot she was unranked like she
ranked like she got into rank like two days ago and
everything um so she had like i had to coach her and kick
you on how to play support because during the first scrims i
had to like guide them on support like how to support all
and everything because during the scrim yuzu um i don't know
if this was during the tournament was this i don't remember
it was a tournament or the scrim but she didn't know when
she didn't know which characters was uh which character
which copy on loki for loki was uh um for sorry i'm
remembering straddle was for aggressive alt and which copy
was for defensive alt so i had to teach her that because
like she was using luna all aggressively i was just like no
that's her only defense song you do stop so i was like don't
do that again you do like He was just like, I was like,
okay, I'm gonna cop.
I was like, okay, we're gonna copy.
We're gonna use it defensively.
And then she copied Luna and like ran into the enemy team.
And I was like, our only defense.
And then she's like, sorry, I tell you.
Cause like, you know, before then she was copying.
She was copying me nonstop.
And I always play the aggressive of it.
But I was like, don't copy.
Because, and I had to swap to, I had to swap to Rocket, I
think.
because of the comp and and so she i was like copy luna you
have to copy luna don't copy me and so she thought that
because i was like don't copy rocket you know i was just
like luna was just better than rocket so i was a teacher and
be like okay um just copy our luna but but and use it
defensively but then and she was like oh i i don't know
which character is like afterwards you know after she's like
sorry i didn't know which one's defensive i was like
aggressively but that's it like everything else defensively
so so from there i was like that like and then also kikyo
like i said i was coaching our support players because
obviously you know i have more of the game sense and
knowledge i had to teach kikyo to be like uh i'm lucky that
no one know how to play phoenix um in the tournament but i
wasn't sure sure because well i know like blur can play
phoenix because he's like versatile and also sk i know blur
and sk and you ought to play phoenix but was like okay uh at
first kikio would throw rocket alts into phoenix alts like
when we you know because it's like stuff like this like if
you know the enemy team has a phoenix um you you don't alt
it's like playing chicken like that's how you have to play
against phoenix when you're rocket so i was just like so at
first she like altered she altered before knowing we knew
phoenix has alt but she still altered so i was just like
during the scrims so i was just like quickly was like yeah
don't do that like next time you play chicken you hold your
rocket all until and because i don't trust my team to shoot
the phoenix because we were literally we came together in
two days i don't think we were that coordinated to shoot the
fucking phoenix all um so i was just like i was like okay we
just wait until the phoenix all then you all next time like
stuff like that i was giving like like for me this is very
common knowledge for me because you know if i don't do it i
get yelled at and i'll start crying um i get yelled at by my
team and then i'm gonna start crying so i had to go through
that you know so but so that's why it's common knowledge for
me but like you know a lot of these players are not in my
rank um my rank to like have that being yelled at them yeah
so so i had to like teach them and be like yeah just make
sure to do this and yeah we learn when we cry yeah so um i
had to like guide them along on um but our team average was
actually quite low um because like you know like i said even
though i'm considered one above all i'm still a support
player so as a support player i know like you're like oh but
you guys you kept everyone but also like I think what helped
me was I could be any role if I was DPS or tank if I was DPS
or tank and I was one above all DPS or tank and I was also
IGLing I could get like 40 kills or like you know like 30
plus final hits as a tank or DPS and also IGL which would
leave a much bigger impact for my team.
But as support, all I could really do is just give them
knowledge, give them comms, and just keep them alive enough
to enable them to do as much as they can through the
knowledge and the damn brag.
No, it's true.
It's true.
You want to know why?
Because Super Gomez had the ring for Heavenly because he
couldn't show up yet.
yesterday for scrims and like we when we won our first game
he had 30 he was like IGLing for us and he had 30 final hits
and 30 plus final hits and IGLing for us and like we won
against a um we were scrimming against a uh yeah and then I
was like please play more like heaven lean like not gonna
get 30 plus final hits on tank bro you gotta play more like
a diamond player like yeah i was like bro uh you gotta play
more like a diamond player bro he's not gonna be doing the
shit you're doing, man.
It's very, it's so poor.
Yeah, they are.
They're very important.
But I would have a much bigger impact as a DPS and tank.
Because, like, I was a one above all DPS player.
Also, I wouldn't do, I would try not to do, like, I would be
like, pop, pop.
Maybe sitting, sort of fade off and teach your teammates.
thinking for a super chat thinking this ain't a realistic
scenario yeah um um yeah so uh so i was really worried
because like i got really worried because like i said i saw
the team averages and everything and we had like you know we
had diamond plays we had diamond play we
two diamond players we had two diamond players two celestial
play celestial three and then celestial two at me and then
we had an underrank and there's some teams that had like uh
two eternities two celestias and a plat and there was like
one that was like gm but i know you're you're very good at
dps like i don't remember the average for that but um the
like and then there's also an eternity player, GM player,
celestial player.
Like, it was, I got really worried because, like, um, the
second highest, that's, like, I got really worried for, for,
like, our team.
And then everyone's practicing, like, Mornington.
Like, everyone was practicing so much.
I saw everyone just hanging out in the VC, and I'm like, oh,
shit, is it bad that we're not hanging out in the VC?
Also, I joined the server late, too, so that was my fault as
well.
There were a lot of things that were my fault.
Um, so, Because like, we could have had three days of
practice, but our team had two days because I joined the
server late.
So as captain, I didn't organize stuff in time for my team
because I joined the server technically like almost a day
late.
So other teams had three days of practice and my team had
two days of practice because of that.
Okay, it was my fault and I felt so bad.
I like apologized and everything.
I'm like, I'm sorry for causing such an issue and such a
commotion about it But it was whether or not I wanted to be
captain or not because I didn't want to be captain I didn't
want the responsibility.
So I joined the server late because me and the organizers
were trying to figure out if I wanted to be captain or not
it's so so that's why i enjoyed this i felt so bad because i
was like i didn't want the responsibility i was so scared
and nervous and like so much pressure and um it wasn't the
highest rank though there's players that were higher ranked
that were captain what are you talking about in some of the
think like the other three teams it wasn't based on rank
what are you guys talking about the other three teams
weren't even based on rank but mine was so i was i was like
that's why i didn't that's why i had that whole discussion
with guys like i don't want to be captain because like like
if i lose they'll be like team donkey bird and then i have
to go to a loser's interview and i was just like bro i don't
know what the mental state right now they go guys no you
don't understand i know you you're like oh well but others
had to lose they were okay with you know doing those
interviews but guys i don't i was already like not okay like
i was just not okay you know like no it was just like i was
i had a lot of stuff going on and i was like super stressed
out That was like super stressed out and like Um Um a lot of
stuff going on and I was just like Pro I'm I'm I don't know
I don't want this to be another minus one Like minus one in
stress or plus one plus one in stress So that's why I was
like I don't talk I won't be captain man Like it's like also
my luck has been really really bad lately So I don't know
like like I've had some really luck things happening to me
so i was just like oh my god this might be another plus one
especially especially in gotcha too yeah yeah gotcha was not
okay it was not on my side like after that dispatch no no i
think dispatch was my breaking point i this match was my
breaking because that was it was at the no it was sorry
battlefield yeah and then the fact that it took a six out
that was the day the six plus hours of battlefield was the
day i crashed out and had a breakdown about whether or not i
should drop out like that was that day because i was like i
played battlefield it took us six plus hours to win and then
the day before that i fucked up 385 percent like rules in
dispatch and
So, yeah.
So, I was just like, I don't know.
So, I was like, this close.
And a huge shout out to the organizers.
Because, like, they had to put up with me crashing out last
night.
They had to put up with me crashing out last night.
Whether or not, like, like, uh, whether or not I was like, I
was like, I was going to be okay.
Like, didn't get, but also, it's just Sea Dogt, too.
because they're like, you want to talk to Seedog?
I was like, I'm too embarrassed, man.
I feel so bad being like such a nuisance right now.
I was like, I felt so bad.
I was just like, I'm sorry.
I don't really want to talk.
And Seedog like reached out to me himself.
You know, I was like, I don't want to talk to Seedog because
I'm very embarrassed.
And he still DMed me about it and being like, are you okay?
Cause I was like, bro, my mental is like not good at the
moment today.
And even he like read like him and the organizer reached out
and was like no we get it we understand we just want to make
sure your mental is okay and i'm like i'll try so so i'm
happy like i was like what if we don't win anything like
what if we don't even win one game like i was really that
fucking deep like i was just like i was like what do we why
do we don't even win one game like i'm so what would i do i
can't show my face to rivals i i can't i can't i was i was
absolutely gonna doom queue for six hours until good night
dragons no jk you know i would you know i would instantly
because that's what i've always done you knew i was gonna
doom queue for
right after we didn't win a single game like
if we lose just goes ahead and wins you guys find a smile
for your talent thank you for the super chat thank you no
yeah because I did it before and I knew I was gonna do it
again um and then it's like eight hours later and
so yeah the obviously the most mentally healthy thing to do
um so yeah no i'm yeah i'm so happy that's why i'm really
proud of my team i'm so proud of my team for being able to
pull this off so a huge shout out to all the individual
players um in my team um but yeah like balila kikyu
um and gomez for coaching like huge shout out to my entire
team where uh or you know playing so fucking well because
it's a team game it's oh it is overall a team game and i
think each of them individually played a part in the victory
like each had their own fucking moments that clutched it up
for everyone um you know they they all had their insane
plays and they all had their own plays that won us certain
maps or certain points and everything um so yeah no they
they like i i'm sorry for doubting my team i i'm sorry for
doubting myself i was doubting myself because i was like i
was i was like what if i felt so bad because they're like oh
i brought up my team average you know um i was like oh no i
i brought up my team average i was gonna feel so fucking bad
if we lose because of me um because you know i was like oh
you guys could have got like a better player than me like or
like an actual high ranker dps player or high rank tank
player so um so i'm just really proud of them um um i know
some oh my gosh i saw like um i'm glad they did balance
stuff again even though it was last minute because like um
alma lee's team was originally gonna have like uh another
eternity support player versus like because like versus like
uh because like sk was supposed to be on a different that's
why there were so many like swaps and changes because sk was
supposed to be on another team and alma lee was was gonna be
like have like another eternity support player but they
swapped it up uh and gave at the like i think it was like uh
three days before the tournament and put sk on amelis team
um and i think that definitely helped balance it a lot more
too so i mean they did a lot of swaps and stuff but yeah sk
was originally not even gonna be on amelis team because of
um because like i think i i i think like some people brought
it up too where like um um amelis team needs player oh yeah
i remember i remember i told you guys i was like bro some
teams have five support players and one tank i remember when
i said that chat i was like bro what the fuck there's one
that's that was amalese team i was like bro bro this team
has five support players and one tank bro i was just like
and then they yeah and then and then they later on they like
swapped sk onto that team to give them a dps player because
because i think like some people were like yeah that's like
rough yeah i remember now i was like bro that's fucking
rough buddy
yeah uh yeah so i was just like oh my god uh The healer,
he'll stop for the win.
So I'm glad they did that.
I thought Amelie's team was so strong.
I honestly, I think they had a lot of really, really close
games.
I think the issue was just counterswapping.
Like I said, Amelie's team was very, very strong in general.
Like on paper.
They were very strong on paper, and a lot of us were very
scared.
very scared um because of it i think it's just more so of uh
of just like it's just counter counter swapping rock paper
scissors it's literally that um they just it just had to be
like they just and also the fact that we all target bond to
silo because we are not dealing with that every team was
balanced in the end yeah
about balancing and stuff um so i'm glad like every uh team
was balanced that was my biggest worry that's why i almost
dropped out too because i was like oh my gosh like i don't
know if this is balanced so like i was just like i don't
know i don't know if it's gonna be balanced because
everyone's playing off-rolls and stuff and i don't know what
their skill level is and
um um but i know that's that's basically it i'm i'm i'm
happy with how uh everything came out in the end you know i
was expecting the worst possible outcome but then you know
it's always nice to be pleasantly surprised that's why i was
expect i don't know i know like i have like you know It's
like, like, what is it called?
What is it called?
Debbie Downer, you know, the typical Debbie Downer shit.
But like, I don't want to go in with high expectations
because I don't want to be disappointed.
I don't want to be disappointed.
So I'm glad things were down.
Pleasantly, you mean like fucking first place?
Yeah, yeah, you'd be pleasantly surprised.
But first place, guys.
Yeah, I got like doom.
I'm like doomer.
Oh my god.
Tomorrow I'm playing art creators.
I'm so tired I'm freaking oh my god.
Wait, I need to check my schedule.
Don't I have like other stuff I have to do in the morning
too?
Oh my god, I do.
I have something I have to do an hour before as well.
Oh my god.
Okay, everything will be fine.
Bro, I'm so out of it.
um uh uh what else am i gonna what else i want to talk about
uh uh uh next week i have a sponsor oh and also i'm next
week i am streaming uh metal gear solid delta that's right
Shout out to Nexy because that was actually a charity
auction reward where she wanted me to play Metal Gear
finally and I will be calling Mint.
Mint.
Oh my god, you know my brain was so frazzled.
I almost called the other name.
That's how tired because I've never done that before.
That's how tired.
Like it was literally like I had I like buffered it.
I had it like my brain buffered it and stopped it instantly
but the it showed up in my head yeah it actually like came
up in my head when I was like mid and then like in my head
it was the other name I I've never the thing is I've never
done that before too that's how fucking tired I am like my
mental my mental blocks are like not working properly uh
Yeah, no, like, I'm super scared.
My mental blocks are actually, like, like, they're being
broke.
Like, it's, like, we're down right now.
Like, no one has been upkeeping it.
Um, um, um, I didn't say it, though.
I, I, the name appeared in my head.
That's why I was like, mint.
so um anyway anyway um what was i gonna say uh we're gonna
mince gonna be like in a call with us while we're playing
with rage baiter i don't know what we're doing i forgot that
she her schedule we were planning on this week and she's
like this is my schedule and then and then i was like yeah
because like she was double streaming and everything and I
was like bro and like she had meetings at night and she's
like oh I could do it after my meetings which was like 10 p
.m.
like it was like what was it like it was like 9 p.m.
or some shit she's like oh I could do it after I was like
bro I'm not scheduling this after your meeting for your
third stream like
yeah I was like you're fucking crazy bro we'll do it next
week man we'll do it next week so um um so yeah so we're i
don't know what day i need like ping you and be like what
day are we doing it again wait what day because like i'm
going by her schedule because her schedule is more fucked up
than mine right now um uh you'll finally get the i don't
think i will i think i'll just be still very confused uh uh
uh i think it was super chat thank you but and also we have
a sponsor next week and after that i don't know what was the
stuff with my schedule i'll figure it out later um um what
else oh there was something else i want to talk about i'm
trying to run oh also i want to say i'm really proud of my
team for being incredibly flexible and we didn't really have
one tricks it was i will say um it was very hard to fucking
figure out what the fuck to do with our limited when Loki
didn't work because Yuzu's hero pool was basically like what
Yuzu's hero pool was she can only play four supports because
she had two days to learn four supports which is already
really good she like okay three days maybe I don't know I
know I knew like she had two to three days to learn as many
supports as possible and she learned but at that time
because I was a day late, uh, because I was a day late to
joining the server, uh, she ended up, she learned Invis,
Gambit, Loki, and Adam, and only those four characters.
Um, and because of that, you know, she didn't know that I
was gonna be Gambit.
She didn't know that I was gonna be Gambit, and Kiki was
gonna be Invis.
Like, that was the main, we're gonna be like, these were the
main rules that we're gonna do and yes kiki already knows
how to do the other supports as well so um it was very
restricting because like yuzu could only do low-key or adam
and she can't play anything else after that so um because
like you know they started batting invis they started
batting invis and then started playing characters that
counter loki so we were and then also gambit they started
batting gambit invis so we're like what do we we're so
that's why i have to go Like, I was like, okay, I'm going to
go on Rocket.
And I had to go on Luna because, like, I'm the most flexible
out of all of us.
So I was like, okay, it's okay.
I'll be Rocket and I'll be Luna.
You can play Adam.
We're going to have to figure out how we're going to, I'm
going to try to coach you on the fly on Adam after you
played Loki for how long, for so many hours.
I'm going to be live coaching you right now in the finals.
is live or die if we lose this we're not first place but
that's no pressure though you know how like because at first
she started she was resing in the middle of everyone as adam
when i said oh play for res and after the first match i was
like hi i had to i was like you suit you gotta hide you see
it and she improved so fucking fast she improved incredibly
fast too afterwards um sink or swim you had no pressure by
the way um in the second game she improved a lot um and I
also obviously I had to call out soul bond too because like
you know the soul bonds also helped out a lot with like all
the other also I was like soul bond soul bond us now so I
obviously I had to do live coaching on the fly to tell her
when to use it.
the abilities too because like they actually saved our lives
like the soul bond saved us too for a lot of things um and
also isa too isa was very versatile you know she wasn't
supposed to be our tank player she was supposed to be like
the tps player and then we put on tank because we're like we
need a tank like so i'm really happy with how versatile
everybody was like you know she wasn't even supposed to play
tank she was like the namor player um but we're like we
ain't playing We're not playing Namor because other teams
know how to counter Namor, but they don't know how to
counter.
They don't really know how to counter.
So she tanked really hard.
Isa did a really good job tanking as well.
And she was very, like, you know, her IGLing was also
pretty, like, she, not co-IGL, like, because she helped with
co-IGL.
Like, I don't know, is it called shock calling?
It was more so of target calling.
She helped out with target calling, you know.
So it helps out a lot with target calling because, like,
people, things, sometimes things weren't dying.
the card could call um but i had to take over at one point
because we're target tiling the wrong thing like they're
like get the they're getting like get this guy that's 20
mile like for it i was like no kill the thing on the card
guys ignore i know they're like kill these supports so they
can't heal the thing on the card i was like guys it's over
time guys it is over time it doesn't matter if like it
doesn't matter we kill the support we have to kill the thing
on the card like We can kill the support later After they're
trying to run to the cart Because it's overtime And they
have to touch the cart Yeah I had to like I had to redirect
the Target calling I was like no Cart I was like Cart guys
That tilted me so hard um um that took me so hard because
there was like a full it was like a fucking hat full hp emma
just chilling in the car and then she like held a oh no it
was a full hp emma on the point while everyone else wanted
to chase kills in front of us i was like guys we need to cap
the point please kill emma like like kill the thing on the
at first before we do anything else like um um but yeah no
isa did a really job heavenly our fucking secret weapon like
um like i said he signed up cps but we put him on tank
because he was our best tank player like he was he was our
he was our actual best tank player because we had no other
even though it was his off roll it was the best tank player
and you know they didn't expect that secret weapon you know
the um the you know he that he was supposed to be like our
other dps player that we like hid that's what i was saying
intel is key i didn't want to leak any of our any of our
strats i was like hide your profiles intel is so important
in these this is why pro players all pro players hide their
match history because they don't want like and that's why
pro players don't stream their scrims um it's similar in any
hero shooter like overwatch they do the same thing um
because you know they there's like a hidden black market for
uh players leaking scrims to other teams and stuff like that
like that's gonna be like bro you got that scrim like you yo
bro didn't you scrim this team last night can we like borrow
can we watch that replay like but we're like dark web of
like like exchanging they're like we're gonna be screaming
this team later that you're gonna face in the in the
tournament so we're like we can and and you know your face
you scream that team and we're gonna be facing them so like
can we like you know like i'll give you our scrim vod and
our scrim replay and then you guys give us your their scrim
replay so like you know for it yeah it's like the intel war
like like info swapping yeah exactly nothing is more
valuable than information and i heard like other teams were
also just studying like um like what so that's why it's like
private your profiles private your profiles and don't talk
about what we're playing because obviously um maybe some one
was like we don't want you know there's like chat hoppers
and stuff like that so um i was like worried about people
like leaking our comms leaking the our comps that we had so
i was like okay i'm gonna do these bad guys look at i'm
gonna type on type and stuff if this happens um because like
that's why they didn't expect us to you know have the comps
we had because i was like no leaks no leaks it was best of
one like like what can i do in that situation it's literally
whoever has the most information wins a best of one because
that shit is scary like i'm so happy we didn't get
domination It's so hard to adjust in domination.
Yeah, so, I mean, we did get domination versus Amelie's
team, but like I said, it was so, so close.
Because in domination, you have to adjust so fucking fast.
Yeah, but yeah, anyway, that was the tournament.
Yeah, I think that's everything about the tournament.
Yippee.
am so tight but thank you guys i'm i am thank you guys for
uh for like all the support for that tournament i'm so sad
that you know my i lagged so hard on the last you know the
finals game like because of youtube like youtube actually
like you i can't have see i told you guys bad luck You know
the most hyped final two three games and then YouTube fucked
me up like I told you I told you I've had such bad luck so
that's why I was like I was just like guys I don't trust
myself anymore I don't trust my luck anymore like um um like
it was like monkey paw you know you
you can win the turn but no one can watch it happen like
like that's so fucked that actually is so fucked um yeah
equivalent exchange right there yeah but your stream gets
cursed um um you guys POVs to see.
Like, the POV of me in the pack.
What else do I want?
What else do I want to talk about?
I'm going to watch a lot because of the YouTube app.
View plus one.
Congrats on the W.
Thank you to Super Chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Cycle.
I really appreciate it.
But, yeah, like I said, thank you all, guys.
You guys all shooting me on.
Like, oh, my gosh.
It's crazy.
I've had so many things happen to me throughout this year.
And I really appreciate all the good things that come my
way.
And, you know, I don't want to take it for granted, you
know.
I don't want to take it for granted.
And, you know, thank you guys.
Thank you guys all for watching.
And I love Rivals so much.
I took it way too seriously.
I know.
I know you guys like, we're like, Toki, it's a for fun
tournament.
I'm like, you don't understand.
It's rivals.
I was like, you don't understand.
It's not, it's not just for fun.
It's life for death.
Like, yeah.
Rivals are die.
Um, but...
Yeah, I'm, I'm just, I'm just, you know, it's been a great
time.
Yeah.
I had a good time.
All right, I'm going to call it here.
I'm going to call it here.
I know this was all just a rival's discussion, but, you
know, I'm fucking celebrating my post win.
Post win, guys.
This is a post win discussion with have time.
Oh, yeah.
Before, before, before any.
before anything else, guys, before anything else.
This is very important.
I got something to show you guys.
Was very important.
But because I won my tournament, I am allowed to keep on
chilling.
Did you guys know that you still have one week left to
pre-order your very own Doki Bird controller?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Want me to keep on winning?
Why not pre-order the Doki Bird controller right now?
Whoa.
Whoa, whoa,
whoa, damn, that looks so good, guys.
Yeah, that could be your, you could have, you could order it
right now.
You say, guys, did you, did you hear about the donkey bird
control?
Anyway, guys, yeah, I'm passing you up, but I'll never
forget the shill.
I'm a businesswoman.
Anyway, I'm actually going to call it here.
I want to fucking go to sleep.
Winning room might be late, or I'm just going to pawn it off
to my manager to make it.
It was likely I'd be like, make this waiting room.
Oh, I want to make...
I'm going to make Bulldog noodles to celebrate.
Yeah!
I got spam.
Okay, I know, like, I shouldn't be cooking.
You know, fuck it.
I'm going to cook.
I don't want to make...
I'm going to make Bulldog noodles.
to celebrate.
I'm going to make my Carbonara Bulldog.
I didn't eat dinner yet.
I'm going to make Carbonara Bulldog noodles.
And then I'm going to put mozzarella cheese on top.
And then I'm going to get it.
Yum, yum, yum, yum.
Alright.
Hey guys.
As always, everybody.
And eggs.
Oh, and scrambled eggs too.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Poster check.
Yeah, but moving around.
Get that.
Blood flowing.
Sorry.
I'm like, what?
What's that liquid inside our bodies to get that blood
placed in for me and Tibet because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.